my guest tonight is a tony and emmy
award-winning actor who played walter
white on breaking bad
now you can see him in the showtime
limited series
your honor i love this show please
welcome brian
cranston brian thank you for being here
in person so good to be
here it's isn't it nice to take it you
left your home and went someplace
to drive to just to get out it means so
much to me
thank you so you don't care about being
here on the show
you just wanted to get out of the house
that's primarily it i have a list of
things i need to pick up at the store
[Laughter]
now you've asked that i interview you
while you shop while you
pick up things at the grocery store well
it'll be as exciting as your other
episodes
zing you know i didn't come here to be
insulted by you wait a minute that's
exactly why i came here
uh we have so much to talk about first
this is a reunion of sorts because i
know you've worked with
the great andy richter before you got
andy you guys have
worked together we have uh a couple of
few times
yeah yeah we did a movie together and
then i was in a
uh an episode of malcolm in the middle
right the movie was a
it was a an adult sex movie so we don't
usually talk about that one but
um but yeah he was terrific
well i've seen the movie four times yeah
you are
forgettable andy richter uh completely
forgettable he is
oh yeah he is an amazing amazing it no
was it
a movie called seeing other people is
this
uh from that movie uh i don't know what
this is from this is a still i was given
that is the two of you oh i think in
this one andy was telling me about his
sexual prowess
and i uh i'm reacting and he's so
rolling
i just was doing that yeah you were just
doing that andy is so proud of working
with you that this is his driver's
license photo
it's the two of you it's it's the only
two-shot
driver's license photo that exists
i was going to say from the lighting of
that you could tell they could afford
him and me
very high budget production very
dim yeah uh as you can see we're being
very coveted safe here andy
you and i are uh more than six feet
apart and andy
i insist it'd be uh 65 feet away from me
it's a court thing for some reason
yeah the restraining order was that was
the minimum
uh you know i did want to ask you a
personal question i've talked to you
several times before
we've always had a wonderful time at
least i have you seem annoyed most the
time yeah
um you have had a wonderful time i've
had a wonderful time talking to you
yeah i've been really enjoyed talking to
you you always seem
yeah take it or leave it um you
have been married 32 years and just an
incredible marriage especially in this
business of show
well it's collective i've been married
five times
i still look at it as a success if you
look at it that way mickey rooney was
married for 160 years
[Laughter]
how did you and your wife meet we met
and we uh we were guest starred my wife
robin dearden was an actor and she's
retired now but um
we met uh doing a show called airwolf
oh my god do you remember this yes i
remember airwolf very very bad show
but with a great thumping theme song
da da da da da and you got excited about
the show and then
slowly as the show rolled out it's like
you started losing interest and so which
means it only ran for like seven seasons
yeah
it did it incredibly well and my wife
was the victim of the week
and i was the bad guy of the week and i
held her
literally held her captive by gunpoint
and
what a weird way to meet because i i met
my wife
uh on a remote 20 years ago shooting a
remote
which i think again that was how i used
to do remotes the only way i could get
anyone to talk to me was i would wave a
gun around and make people
no i didn't do but i'm saying yours is
so much stranger
that you met your wife your first
introduction to her was you
holding her hostage with a fake gun
well it's also very sexy i think though
it's like
she thought i was very dangerous
you guys have that chemistry right away
we did and you know why
i think we've been married for so long
is because at that time that's 35 years
ago now
35 years ago i had a girlfriend she had
a boyfriend
so we didn't have these the the need to
to make a move we were able to play and
flirt and yet
to not have anything go any further than
that so we were able to really be
ourselves and
and say god she's really pretty and
funny and
yeah i really like i had that same thing
with my wife when we met
i was very asexual and so there was no
threat that i would you know what i mean
and
then i just eventually sort of sort of
evolved in this other
direction into like let's like a battery
now you're double a or triple a section
yeah that's one of those
you know i remember it's so funny that
you met on airwolf because i remember
that theme
so well the opening show i do and
basically i hate to admit this but it's
how i start
most of my mornings as i play the
airwolf theme
i think we should take a look right now
ladies and gentlemen the opening to air
wolf
it's pretty badass
what a different time in television it
is
when you know they spent a fortune on
uh just the theme song and the the
visuals this was seven minutes of
the show i know you know it's incredible
watching this now
you realize it goes on for another six
and a half minutes i know
first of all let's make let's be clear
to our viewers that is for anyone
younger people cannot believe how long
show openings used to be
and what happened is they've now
completely gone away
there's there's a quick yeah
you know and uh and and then you're
right into it
that is a small fraction of the opening
of that show
you haven't even gotten to and it's
unbelievable chips the opening to chips
i clocked it once at 45 minutes
the the actual story is only six and a
half minutes
after that and then they wrap it up
what's like the hawaii 5-0 was
also another big driving emotionally you
know
exciting hawaii experience yes wow
no it tells you how much television has
changed that
there used to just be so there were
three networks there was a limited
number of
amount of product you would watch a long
opening even if it wasn't great
because what else you gonna do it's the
70s or the early 80s what do you got to
do pal
and i heard the concept of having the
big
sound the big music intro was
because in commercial television
broadcast people would leave the tv on
go for
go to the bathroom and go to the kitchen
and they would hear that music start to
play
and it was like a siren call they'd come
back in oh the show's starting
and that would draw their attention back
to it that's when we were
locked into a time and a day we had to
watch our show
yeah now it's you don't imagine no but i
mean it's
it is so different now i try to explain
this to my children and i sound like
my dad talking about the great
depression when i was growing up and i
was like what do you
who cares and he'd say no i'm telling
you it listened to a radio and it had a
curved top
who cares now i'm telling them you had
to line up and
you had to watch that show and when it
came on or you'd miss out buddy boy
they don't tell you yeah i don't know
why i talked that way uh
uh i i did want to ask you this uh i
know that
we're being very coveted safe you and
your wife
contracted kovid fairly early on in the
pandemic is that right
we didn't have it and we had to hire a
contractor to make sure that we got it
it was very important to us how much did
it cost was
very expensive you don't want to go to
the cheapest one you don't want to go
there
and you don't want to go to the highest
price so we found someone right in the
middle
nice dose of covered that was uh almost
a year ago
wow in march of last year and how bad
was it the 2020 the greatest
uh year of our lives uh it what we were
very lucky
yeah actually we i had about two and a
half three days of
of body aches you know when you feel
like a flu is coming on
yeah but it stayed there it didn't nail
me
i never was forced to stay in bed but
it just didn't feel right and and
exhaustion
pure exhaustion for a week i couldn't
take enough naps
i would go for a walk and have to sit
down again and
it was it was exhausting a little bit of
of a heaviness in my chest for
maybe a half a day and that was it
wow so he got lucky except i lost
my sense of taste and smell oh you did i
did which is a very common
side effect yeah and you smell very good
and i was disappointed coming here today
knowing that i wouldn't be able to smell
you i have a pine scent
that yes people find adorable very
outdoorsy um
did you i would think there are a lot of
downsides to losing your sense of smell
obviously not being able to taste
incredible foods
there's got to be some upsides yeah yeah
you
what you don't smell the dog poop you
don't smell the vomit that someone just
it's like hey that's pretty good in fact
and i do it because i stick my nose
right in it and go
nope i don't smell it i get it
no because i saw you
three months ago i talked to my podcast
your face was covered in dog [ __ ] and
you didn't seem to care
well because i didn't smell it and it
was a podcast it wasn't tv
[Laughter]
i need a little help i need a little
help you dated a woman once who had no
sense of smell
i did and it was great
i could eat anything at any time any
hour of the day
be like a man and have as much gas as i
damn well please
and she couldn't smell a damn thing and
that was probably the whole
basis of the relationship it was the
baby you guys didn't you hadn't you felt
no love for her at all
none but it's it was so it
it was so advantageous because of her
inability to smell anything
one time we were in a car we were
driving
and we had been dating for quite a while
now and we're driving
and she just turns and looks to me and
gives me a scornful look
and i went what what she goes i can't
smell anything
but my hearing is fine
i forgot about that part yeah i got a
little relaxed
you uh of course you you hear this all
the time
but uh and you're allotted for your
acting ability one of the things that i
find
most incredible about what you're able
to do is
you're one of the funniest performers
that i've seen and you're also able to
as we all know just nail drama
and i'm wondering what is your secret
weapon what do you think is your secret
weapon
in your acting career what have you got
what have you got that you can always
rely on is there something about your
face that you think
helps you yeah i mean i i
i have that uh kind of uh resting face
that is
has scorn and anger and
and uh you know i mean it's just
yes look of uh in consternation and
intensity oh yeah
yeah i don't think anybody has the
consternation phase that well
i i take that back because you had clint
eastwood
oh my god and and harrison ford perhaps
and
but i'm consternation in my resting face
look here
recipe no emotion not thinking of
anything
consternation right there so
so i look i look that already
then you enter a real dilemma and boy it
just compounds
wow and people think that i'm i'm
actually thinking of something and i'm
like right now when i'm talking to you
i'm actually thinking of lunch
so you're not engaged in this interview
not at all you you haven't
thought about anything i've said you
haven't even listened to me i did listen
to you
when i first got here and you said hey
good to see you yeah and then after that
you've been checked out
you're such a good actor that you appear
to be engaged in this interview
but now you're telling us you're
somewhere else
you're not even here at this moment i'm
sorry said
um let's let it go okay you um
you're a bad man people need to know
that what well you know what i mean
when i say bad i mean just evil uh
you know last time you and i talked uh
we were talking about motorcycles you
still ride a motorcycle
or i know you had a whole period of your
life yeah in your youth where you
crisscross the country on a motorcycle
and i'm curious is that still a part of
your life at all have you given it up
completely i'll tell you
i used to have a harley and uh
traveled the country for two years on a
motorcycle back in the 70s and i had a
harley for years
now i've got a got a scooter
yeah and it's called a fat scooter
and i crisscross ventura boulevard
nothing scares me man i'm gone
look out yeah and you keep diaries you
keep like your road diaries yeah
crossing ventura boulevard
a bug splattered on my eyeglasses
keep that one that'll go in the memoir
yeah that's very nice
yeah you talked about those days and how
you would
you would ride your motorcycles back in
the 70s you would ride your motorcycle
you'd
camp out you'd go to sleep in the dark
not even knowing half the time where you
were
betting down for the night you'd just
lay down someplace and then in the
daytime you'd realize where you were
yes so my brother and i were together
and now we were in our early 20s and we
took off from california
and i had 175 dollars in my pocket so
that doesn't that doesn't last that long
but
in the 70s uh it wasn't a litigious
society it didn't it wasn't overburdened
by paperwork so you can get a job
anywhere anytime you walk into a
restaurant that's super busy and go look
do you want me to bust tables yeah would
you here's 20 bucks
i'll bust for a couple hours i get fed
and then i'm
done and it's like we did that all the
time
it was it was kind of nice and then
we're pulled into a city
and basically we had a rule if you're in
a city and it's the weak day
then you would look for a church or a
synagogue or someplace and you
go drive in the back and usually they
have a little square of grass you can
throw your sleeping bag down and they
didn't really care
if you if it's a weekend you look for a
school and so we did that a lot
sometimes you can't find anything at
night and we saw this park
and there's a fence and these beautiful
trees and there's all this grass over
there so we
threw our sleeping bags over climbed the
fence went out into the grass
away from the trees we didn't want
anything falling on us and we
went to bed and the next morning we
we're like oh it's like
just sun is starting to come up and
we're starting to
come awake and
i look over and there's a golf ball
and then there's another golf ball there
sorry we were one of the hazards
so you're in a driving range essentially
you're on a golf course
it's insane and then one time we did the
same thing
we were so tired that we we thought we
saw a park
we climbed a fence against got to a
grassy area
and then we're putting things down and i
realized
oh i can put my things against this
stone
this headstone oh we were on a cemetery
right but we were so tired we thought
you know what the hell with it
you have to be pretty tired to say ah
what are they going to bother us
yeah no um i want to talk about
uh your honor which i i i love this show
oh good and um i actually
uh got very wrapped up in it it's a
fantastic idea for show
and one of my favorite things about the
show is how
um your character uh this this judge is
a very
decent uh you know um is very decent
person with a very strong moral code
who has to make these decisions to save
his son
and so every step of the way i
understand why are characters doing
what they're doing and at the same time
these are decisions which are go against
everything that you believe is right
that's what got me hooked on this show
to do it in the first place was that
premise
of if you really thought your child
was in danger of being killed what would
you do right
to protect him or her in anything
everything and i talked to any parent
and they said
yep i would become a criminal i would
and that my character is a superior
court judge and he does
he lies to authorities which is a crime
he
destroys evidence he creates alibis he
manipulates juries
he's doing whatever he can to keep his
son alive and
each step it's going so against his
principles that it's eroding his soul
it keeps going deeper and deeper and
deeper
and i also love that it takes place in
new orleans which
to me i would want to if i was ever
involved in some showbiz venture and
they said
pick a city where it's going to happen i
might choose new orleans
just for the food alone yeah you know
that's not going to happen for you
that's i mean
you don't think they're not going to say
be involved in an entertainment program
of some sort
i don't think i think you've shot your
wad here
i think i'm doing really well brian
thank you
right i talk till i'm blue in the face
how has it been for you all these years
my friend
where you have to you have to walk that
line between
being supportive and being sycophantic
you don't want to
be an ass kisser but you you have to you
have to support him but
have you ever really just come out and
told the truth about a monologue that he
did and said that was terrible
uh no i just i just general
not specifically i just generally keep
him frightened of me
oh yeah yeah yeah andy early on
um sort of intimated that he had a very
violent temper
and he's also physically one of the
strongest people i've ever met
so the first thing i do to every day at
work is i come in and i have a pumpkin
and i crush it in my hands
and then we're fine yeah wow so i don't
mess with andy
also i will say in andy's defense after
all these years of working together he
does not lie
i've never seen him laugh at something
genuinely laugh at something
that he didn't think is funny and you
can go back and look at
thousands and thousands of hours of late
night shows plenty of times he is not
laughing
that yeah there have been people who
have pointed that out yeah
yeah like after after a segment and gone
like man you weren't much help but i'm
like
yeah yeah yeah and it's so funny because
if we have someone great and funny
if a brian cranston's on andy's in there
he's yucking it up
he's coming up with great things when
i've had people on that are giving me
nothing
andy leans back crosses his legs
and just says you're it's your plane and
it's going down
good luck to you and afterwards i'll be
like what the hell and he's like hey
you know what do you want me to do get
my get my hands dirty trying to help you
and that's it
yeah yeah that that came to an end yeah
that's i understand that
now i do you know i know that you think
it's unlikely that i will become
a serious actor of great renown uh but
i did mean what i said i would want to
be in new orleans
are you eating the food because i see
there there was one episode i saw we
were having this giant shrimp dinner and
it looks fantastic and i'm thinking are
you eating that food or are you one of
those actors that pretends
i always eat the food that's get on a
set
even when i'm not supposed to i'm i
that's always been a pet peeve of mine
to see a scene
at a thanksgiving dinner or something
and and people are kind of pushing
around the
food and no one's really eating and
everybody's like ha ha ha
i was like i don't believe that yeah i
mean part of
part of creating a dramatic
interpretation
of a scenario is to to be as real as
possible
eat the food and so you'll see me
chowing down that was real shrimp
yes and we were dipping in the sauce
some was hotter than others
your eyes are watering it was it was
great
that's one of my pet peeves uh about uh
john cryer who i love i love john cry
who doesn't love john cryer
love that guy uh and i think he's
hilarious and a terrific actor
two and a half men anytime that shows on
and he's eating i noticed he's just
pushing the food
and pushing it around and i john crier
eat the food
eat the food when you're doing a scene
that show's gonna go nowhere
[Applause]
my prediction now what is your uh okay
so you eat the food what about love
scenes what's your technique in life eat
the food and love scenes
[Laughter]
i've noticed that whenever you have a
sex scene and throughout your career
uh you're always you've got food on the
nightstand
food and you're taking a lot of breaks
to eat oh yeah food whipped cream
strawberries yeah yeah
no i want to be authentic so i have to
go to my partner
and say we really have to have sex
or we're liars or we are just
charlatans
and how's that go over i've several
lawsuits which i can't talk about
i've still got my fingers crossed it's
going to work someday uh-huh yeah
[Laughter]
you know i very much i'm a fan of the
show your honor
and uh very happy for you that it is uh
such an excellent
show um and i wanted to show a clip
from the show and then it turns out well
here's the problem because it it's it's
behind
it's apparently i'm not allowed to show
a clip why i
we we went to get a clip they said we
can't release a clip to you
i said it's me conan o'brien oh is that
that
anyone but conan answer that is that the
thing
god i hate hearing that i actually did
try to we tried to get a clip my
producer called me and he said
no they won't release a clip from your
honor it's this new world we live in
a paywall i suppose something's going on
uh i don't know what it is
so if we we have to show some clip
okay so here we go
oh my god those are intense eyes and
michael vincent
yeah and i think this show again was on
for seven
years i think it was something like that
um yeah no but you know it's funny
because uh
i talked to you recently uh and and was
so clear to me when i was talking to you
that one of the things you're proudest
of
is that you have been for many many
years this journeyman actor you have
made your living
as an actor and i think people just
focus on
oh my god there's this massive hit
breaking bad and it's this
iconic worldwide phenomenon and what
they forget is all the years
where you were bad guy number two in
uh in in a show that ran in the 80s that
most people are not even thinking about
anymore and that that
is a big part of the trade for people
that get into acting
that that is it and you're lucky to get
that the transition in that show you're
you're talking about i was i was very
fortunate because i was
cast as bad guy number three and
i was promoted to back guy number two
uh what is true is that for an actor the
you get those hotel clerk
busboy drunken frat boy all those guys
and when you finally get a name it's
like oh
god i'm daryl i'm daryl you know you're
so excited
if you get a last name you've made it
you have you have
made it remember the last name i am
we've made it very clear i am not an
actor
and never should be an actor but early
on when i first got out to la like in 85
86 um someone saw me somewhere
being amusing and they said oh uh i
recommended you to a casting agent for a
jim henson
show uh with not puppets but
with uh you know uh live performers and
i remember that i
knew nothing about it and they sent me
the sides the script
and um the script they sent me had two
characters in it
and they didn't tell me which character
i was supposed to audition for and i was
confused and i said can you send me the
script
can you send me anything more so they
just sent me a sheet that described what
each character
was and the first one was dirk every man
wants to be him every woman wants to be
with him
and i remember going like it's not dirk
and then
and then the second one was like you
know gormley
and it was like gormley he's as goofy as
he is nerdy
he's he's a really skinny doofus
who's never once who's never lost his
virginity and i was like
it's this guy sure enough i show up and
they're like oh how'd you know
i once got set a script and the part
that they wanted me to read
within the text of the script was like
say the guy's name was jerry
jerry comma 32 a complete piece of [ __ ]
and we thought of you
so what part of a big piece of [ __ ] made
you think about me
yeah we can't just give you the role
you understand because there are other
pieces of
[ __ ] in town that are pretty damn stinky
i would see the same pieces of [ __ ] in
every waiting room in town
every time you show up three other
pieces of [ __ ] are there hey [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] for brains hey hey i want to
mention this
uh you and a young gentleman a
struggling actor named aaron paul
have a mescal together dos ombres yes
and
um tell me what it's like what's the
process like of picking
i mean you guys did you go through a
process of tasting a million messed
calls to make sure that you got the one
that said this is us this is what we
believe in that's exactly right
uh aaron loves a strong scotch
slap you in the face kind of drink ah
i like to be seduced and i when i taste
something is like my art or
architecture i like to be oh what is
that and be drawn
in but i i don't want to be abused
so we had to find one juice that
appealed to both of our tastes and
del sumbres is it and you know what this
is available everywhere we didn't
uh why you brought this did you bring it
yes i did i brought that and
this is just for me alone yeah go ahead
swig it
oh that's very good actually that is
very good that is
you know what it is it's smooth
okay you might want to ease up a little
bit on that you know what we're actually
taping this at 12
30 in the afternoon yeah so um
you really do uh you go strong on that i
commit which has always made me
a terrific potential actor
yeah i'm a little concerned about you
right now though
you should be yeah you should be uh this
is very very good andy have you had this
yeah aaron brought it to the show uh a
while ago and it's delicious it's really
good
we are andy and i are so cheap that we
won't go out and buy
this wonderful mezcal we just keep
either booking you
or aaron you always bring it and the
minute it gets low we reach out again
regardless
last time aaron wasn't even pushing
anything he was like i don't have a i'm
not pushing anything we're like you've
got to come we've got to talk to you
and you should probably bring some dos
hombres bring the dos hombres because
we're running low
um andy do you want some i'll get some
after we're done
see you know i was going to pass it down
to you
you are the biggest piece of [ __ ] i'm
telling you
you really are yeah you know you got to
do uh
what god's given you that's what you got
to work with
my dad told me when i was young you're a
piece of [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah he's like i'm gonna be the best
pizza
i think that's called leaning in yeah
leaning into it yeah
yeah you got it well i do congratulate
you sincerely your honor
is a wonderful show it airs sundays at
10 p.m
uh on show time and uh airwolf
uh i don't know how you see airwolf
where is it here
on youtube yeah i'm sure you can find
clips of airwolf on youtube
and uh and watch the beginning several
times every morning and it wakes you up
like a
strong cup of coffee uh brian cranston
you are
an amazing talent and also one of the
nicest people i've met
in this foolish business we're in so
thank you very much for gracing our
presence you're a real class actor good
to see you again
good to see you too be well yes